always always sell a bit of Sam in every
role I mean I don't know if I can say
iconic about myself I think I got to say
something
[Music]
else Iron Man 2 I got a call from FAO
about originally the first Iron Man and
then then I never heard anything so
Downey got it and that was it Tony and I
Tony I love Tony St Tony loves me we're
not competitors my partner was in the
movie Leslie Bib and so I had dinner
with those guys before opening night and
they were nervous about it and then of
course it was a big hit and then my
friend Justin thow was going to write
the script he knew Downey from Tropic
Thunder and I went over to his house and
I said what's going on with that Iron
Man he said I'm flying out tomorrow to
go help fav write the script and I go
well let me be in it I want to be in the
movie write me a part as a bad guy all
right let me talk to Fabro they talked
to Mickey RoR and they decided to split
the villain into two villains there he
is there he
is what out of that absolute pleasure
welcome oh goodness gracious can we get
the handcuffs off my friend here it was
an emergency situation but literally we
wrote a speech at at lunch Robert
Downey's wife was there she helped and
FAO and and uh Kevin and Jeremy was in
my ear it was really it was fun same
thing with all the guns with Don Cheeto
this is the FN 2000 from Belgium they
two make something better than
waffles it's beautiful but I can tell
this isn't disco enough for you so I'm
going to put it right here I memorized
all the guns and then they changed the
guns on Me on the day you had to use an
earwig eventually which is kind of like
a modern Q card you know I was just me
messing around James Brown kind of stuff
fever just said go dance and that was it
is there any chance of Justin Hummer
being bug for our more worse I mean
listen man I'm I'm around let's do
it three Billboards outside eing
Missouri I think came across real good
the things you saying came across his
stupid ass andin about time you got home
to your mama
Dixon no any time I got home to my mama
mama I told her I was going to be out
till 12 actually Dixon is a very
complicated character who been through a
lot of stuff and it's a kind of
redemption story it's a classic kind of
anti-hero I did some ride alongs in LA
with the cop and then I went to Missouri
Martin didn't want a strong Ozark accent
so we found this cop and he had the
perfect amount of a twang he read my
lines and instead of the county he said
the Clank and a couple of things like
get out of my ass he said to when I say
to the deputy get out of my ass Mrs
Hayes have a seat what is it I can do
for you today that came from from this
cop I met with some burn victims the
skin graft doctor and just kind of
trying to get a sense of what that was
like to be burned like that it was very
in-depth I mean I had time that's the
luxury of having time to prep you don't
always have that ladder's pretty steady
as it is there
James no that's okay I I like holding
ladders takes me out of myself we had
Peter Dinklage you know he was hot off
Game of Thrones so famous you know he
was there in this little town town
outside of Asheville so they were real
excited we were
there
Vice hey hey hey all
right let's slow
down enough of that guys oh my God we
were on the Oscar campaign for three
Billboards while I was prepping the
George Bush vice uh Extravaganza and so
I was listening to his audio book I was
watching his interviews it was just
George W bush like nonstop well I used a
lot of Ad Libs from him doing the Jimmy
Kimmel show and I would use a lot of his
vernacular from that major combat
operations in Iraq have ended in the
Battle of Iraq the United States and our
allies have prevailed because I was
talking like this the I got this muscle
got overworked and then then this muscle
was twitching and I didn't know what it
was so I was freaking out I was taking
like magnesium to relax it and stuff
like that and as soon as the movie was
over the twitch went away you don't go
blabbing about what cards you have I
missed my flush draw about a month
ago but everybody still seems to think I
have pocket kings except maybe
halderman Steve's the best man he's the
best and Christian's really uh great
he's a lot of fun we would talk in the
voices but just kind of about normal
things sometimes the supporting rules
are Flash that makes an impact you know
and you don't get sick of them too you
know cuz they're not always
there The Green Mile what's it now
moving there y'all want to come on in
here and dust little you can shine my
knob for me while you're in well that
character aside from being a despicable
person was also very uh funny he had a
lot of funny dialogue so that was easy
to do and there was a appalachi an
accent and my acting coach told me to
watch clogging which is kind of a
hillbilly tap dancing if I watch Beetle
Juice for that I remember I watched
things like Deliverance actually one of
the guys in Deliverance is in The Green
Mile I think he's the Executioner here
come to boss man you'll keep a Cil Tong
on my
[Music]
block I don't know if I actually spit
but he he was ready to take it he was
cool with it yeah we used egg whites for
the drool and then we had some chocolate
paste we had to squirt in in a turkey
baster in his face and Oscar winning
makeup artist Lois Burwell had to paint
zits on my buttex and everywhere else
liver spots on my face and devils in the
details you know you really the details
really add up to a character it creates
a a full-blown three-dimensional person
kind of a human pus ball Stephen King
did show up to set I think he got in the
electric chair for 2 seconds he gave
gave us his Blessing and he was very
happy with it I think we were very
faithful to the
book AR gu but by the time I've broken
his wrist and his pistol falls into your
lap perhaps he will have built up little
trust with one another and you'll be
able to accept two key realities reality
one you are in grave danger reality two
when I say it's time it would really be
beneficial for you to hold on to me as
tight as you can I think I was lucky to
get the role he's kind of the average
duckling becomes a swan you know he he's
kind of like Albert Brooks and Broadcast
News has a little bit of Harrison Ford
Han Solo Steve McQueen a little Bill
Murray a little Jack Nicholson you know
and Cuckoo's Nest he's your typical kind
of irreverent anti-hero like a Han Solo
kind of guy here we
go I love this book doing action for
Matthew vaugh is a trip it's stylized
it's it's very athletic you have to be
in shape it it's a workout you're moving
very fast and you got to be precise it's
a lot like a dance a lot of rubber
knives you know and and a lot of stunt
guys taking really big hits so it was a
complicated number for
sure Confessions of a dangerous mind I'm
Chuck Chuck Baris yeah yeah you wrote
that Palisade song I really like that
song Oh thanks yeah it's real
sentimental I Met George cloney
on a movie called welcome to Collinwood
and then he wanted me to do Chuck bars
and it was based on a book that Chuck
bars wrote where he said he was a spy in
addition to being a TV producer and the
host of a show and so Charlie Kaufman
took the book and wrote a script an
amazing script and everybody wanted to
play it I think Johnny Depp was attached
and came down to me and Ben Stiller we
screen tested then George gave me a
camera once I got the part and a video
camera told me to hang out with Chuck so
I hung out with Chuck Baris like night
and day just hung out with him filmed
him talked with him had him tape my
lines and sort of absorbed him like a
sponge I don't know man to this day I
don't know Chuck said he killed these
people and he was a spy and I couldn't
tell you can you please tell me what a
girl is like who has never been on a
Matt Damon was in the movie and he
helped me find somebody to learn like
fight stuff some of that Jason Bourne
stuff and he got me hooked up with this
guy which probably came in handy for
Argy actually but none of that stuff
ended up in the movie I brought P that
was a favor to George people show up for
George cloney they love
George
Galaxy
Quest fans right hey gr oh hey man I
want to thank you for that nice intro
you gave us today um guy probably don't
remember me do you it's the sunglasses
right I was on the show in ' 82 episode
81 got killed by a lava monster before
the first
commercial I took a lot from Bill Paxton
and aliens and Michael Keaton and night
shift those were my two go-tos for that
there's always a little Bill Murray in
there and I was a little young for the
role they wanted an older guy so we kind
of made him look a little older we got
this mustache and we slick back his hair
it was a wild character
yeah even if it's a comedy to me it's a
drama you know what I mean you have to
be really scared so you're really
freaking out you have like three cups of
coffee and have a panic attack on a
spaceship but it's
real
it's not funny if it's not real farce
has to be high stakes and and
real
guy so many different styles darl
Mitchell and Tim Allen were comedians
Tony and I and Sigourney and Alan
Rickman of course the late great Allan
Rickman were theater actors we had so
many people on that Missy Missy pile and
Patty brain oh and the great enrio with
that whole way that the aliens talked we
have mod every aspect of our society
from your example and it has saved us
you know en Roo came up with that it was
just nonstop and Dean peraso was a great
director it was a really lucky thing
that film if there was a sequel to
Galaxy Quest we would we would be on it
we talked about it maybe like a limited
series yeah Simon Peg talked about do
helping out with it
actually Charlie's Angels so what's so
special about your
software oh oh it's really it's really
quite amazing we developed a program you
see uh everyone's voice is unique it has
a unique signature the audition for that
was a scene from Foul Play you this
movie Foul Play with Chevy Chase Golding
so we didn't have a script really was
script was sort of all over the place
had 17 writers and only one of them was
a woman and it was a movie about women
but then you know Mitch Glazer Bill
Murray's writer showed up and he helped
me a lot and then MCG and I said let's
make the guy like Richard Gear here in
American jiggalo but first we need him
to be kind of like harmless and like
kind of like Spike Jones or Bill Gates
and so we came up with this soft and
cuddly you know software engineer and
then we switched it and made him kind of
dangerous and R out of Richard Gear and
it was kind of that was that was the
Prototype KNX technolog voice
identification software
download and I don't think anybody saw
it coming maybe some people
did
FY verden a lot of people don't know
maybe about who Bob fossy was you know
Michael Jackson was a big fan of he
wanted Bob to direct thriller so you see
a lot of uh Bob's moves and Michael's
moves you know if it's something like
George Bush or Bob FY or Chuck bars
there's a a little bit of an
impersonation especially George Bush
because he's so famous you know that's
like playing Elvis but you don't want it
to overwhelm the
interpretation did we fire him I'll give
the man another shot still learning
break the
leg oh
this that's nice show me the reverse it
was one of the hardest I learned how to
dance and we had to lose the weight you
know because he he was also a speed
addict in addition to being what is
almost like a pro aete and then always
smoking cigarettes you know like I saw
Bradley Cooper with all the cigarettes
as Maestro I mean I I know that's it's
just every scene and it doesn't matter
whether it's the fake one or the real
one it's just it's every smoke in your
face every day so it's a lot uhhuh what
do you say we dive right into the deep
end I don't want to waste time
foot around with the script SC let's
bite the bullet start with the dailies
for mine here see we kind of TR it's
such a long shoot and it's that
repetitive thing and you have a real
beard under a fake beard and you know
you're like you're it's you're getting
up at 5:00 in the morning and you hit
the gym and then you're on a meal plan
you're working on the weekends you're
memorizing lines especially with
something very very long like that you
have to you have to stay grounded and be
patient otherwise you can you can slowly
go
crazy The Hitchhiker's Guide to the
Galaxy this guy boring you watch you
talk to me instead there was a like L
off Fair kind of quality to him you know
he's like this easygoing guy who's the
president of the Universe I wasn't the
first choice for that I think it was
Will faroh Jim Carrey and then I got
that part I Met originally for Ford
prefect I watched a lot of things for
that I watched Jim Carrey and The Mask
Matthew McAn Point Break actually
Spicoli and Fast Times Arthur this is
Zod bble Brocks president of the Galaxy
he's my cousin he's a a semi half
brother he's a really charismatic guy
great Storyteller he has a special thing
he's just got a real authenticity about
it
him Seven
Psychopaths stop so he took out a stop
thr stop stop stop stop what yeah
what I don't think that's a very nice
story I want to know what happens at the
end Chris Watkin is the greatest one of
the greatest actors we're friends we did
a play together we did the movie both
with Martin MCD and then we might do
another Martin McDon movie you know he's
done all the great Shakespearean roles
and that's why he's so good in he's when
he's got a monologue like in Pulp
Fiction or something I mean I grew up
watching him so I learned instinctively
working with him once on in the desert I
I I saw him do five different takes and
I felt like I was watching the deer
hunter The Dead Zone you know all of his
his work was flashing back to me as I
was I was doing the scene with him what
happened to
you I got in a fight in my audition who
at this time the director guy he broke
his nose
how are you ever going to get a job
Billy if you break the director gu's
nose before you even got the part I
didn't mean to break his nose his nose
was just in the middle of where I was
punching Kathy Bates and misery I think
I watched Travis pickle and taxi driver
that guy in the Grizzly Man that
documentary a little lost that guy you
know and vulnerable what the hell did
you
do I set the car on fire the silly bear
hat with the straps and Seven
Psychopaths that was we found that at a
truck stop on the way to Joshua Tree and
column was going to wear it and they
said no you wear it and that was was
more right for
you
Moon Wo tough guy listen to me you look
like a what radioactive tampon wasn't
supposed to look like a banana with a
yeast
infection listen to me I wasn't supposed
to find you Nathan Parker Alan Parker's
son wrote the original script and then
we kind of tweaked we put more humor in
it in the beginning cuz it was very dark
he was having a long-distance
relationship and I was far away from my
partner my new girlfriend at the time we
bonded on that kind of isolation in the
space station and and what that feels
like to be separated from your loved
ones and you know what they do in
interstellar and Robinson cruso and that
kind of thing should we uh should we
playing
yeah you get both clones in the same
shot in the same frame you'd be looking
at a tennis ball and we would shoot
usually the the the dominant the Clone
driving the scene first we watched dead
ringers with Jeremy Irons a lot of it
depended on sound too because on the day
you can't see what's happening sound guy
put it on my iPod and I watched the
previous day guys I was getting hair and
makeup for the other clone so if the
clone's coming towards me and I have an
earwig and I hear the paddle drop and
then I know to retract if he's coming
towards me so it's very technical it was
nice to meet him he came to Sundance and
sting was a part of it cuz Trudy Styler
produced it and saved us and gave us
money there's a lot of little movies
like that that that go into the red you
work really hard you know there's a
movie called The Winning Season I did
with Rooney Mara and Emma Roberts where
I've did a lot of research nobody saw it
really and uh there's a movie called
snow angels really good movie David
Gordon green directed a lot of cool
movies